when you play a real-life guy is it
necessary to meet the guy who you all in
I would Gary it was Gary Hart yeah I
felt that was really important I'm super
nervous about betraying the worst three
weeks of his life I mean the movies but
unbelievable it's the movie is called
frontrunner my name is Gary Hart I'm
running for president for those of you
who don't know the Gary Hart story but I
feel like everybody does know this story
the guy was a popular US Senator
brilliant politician yeah then he was
gonna be the next president but he was
[ __ ] around on his wife yeah but let
me understand how this works yeah in
other words you're tapped by Jason
Reitman yep and Jason says I want you to
play Gary Hart right you say to yourself
I wouldn't mind meeting with Gary Hart
to maybe get in his head so I can think
like Gary Hart yeah because I'm an actor
I want to figure this guy out
Yeah right you're going full Daniel
day-lewis you're trying to say hey man I
got to get into this guy's head right
but the real thing for me was I wanted
to look him in the eye and say I'm not
taking the piss here like I I get this
is your life and I get this is your
legacy and I respect you and I'm gonna
take it seriously and I'm gonna do and I
kind of wanted him to that's the tonight
right you write to someone write a
letter and say hey you Jackman wants to
meet with you because he's playing Gary
Hart right we got introduced via email
does he have financial interest in this
no none none and wouldn't he be like hey
[ __ ] you don't bring this up it's an
embarrassment in my life I don't want to
meet with you Jackman what would
motivate him to meet with you yeah that
was he mmm interesting I think he's just
a decent man like who understood
probably where I was coming from and he
felt there was good intentions with the
movie he had not read the script right
right which was smart right because what
if he hated it and then he's got a
publicly distanced blah blah blah so but
the book had come out Matt buys book
right or the truth is out which he had
worked with Matt for a long time and
that's when the public perception of
what had happened started to change so
that was because there was so much
misinformation about it we service going
to meet with oh yeah where do you go to
meet with him in this house yeah and he
picked me up at there but we really live
so just outside Denver like he got a
whole spread like a rancher yeah yeah
he's gets amazing he's got like 100
70 acres there and then he invited me up
what would he like to drink what do you
like at the airport at the curbside what
he's at the curbside you gonna are you
with people or are you alone I'm on my
own and then I a car will Gary Hart
former standard right and I go to meet
him at the curbside that the trunk of
the car is open yeah and I was nervous
man I was really nervous I didn't know
what that moment was gonna be like and
we've got a 45-minute drive back to his
house and can't even believe he did this
he shook my hand yeah and I'll never
forget it you shook my hand and then
with the other hand he placed it on my
cheek like it was that's really weird it
was amazing it was kind of his way of
going it's gonna be okay don't worry he
wanted to calm you down
yeah so how long did you spend with this
guy you go out three days three days
yeah you lived at his ranch yeah for two
nights three days he makes a mean
martini let me tell you and and and he's
he doesn't mind me telling you this but
he's wife had just had hip surgery
elective hip surgery and she's an
amazing woman Lee and so their bedroom
is upstairs so she can't climb the
stairs because she just had surgery
right and so they're in the fold-out
couch in the den downstairs and he goes
you just take our room and I was like
wow
at least help me went up and I slept in
his bed and he just cleared a little
space in his closet and you guys looked
at to Lee's sink there and you just used
my side here and so it was I would you
know what I would never let use my bed I
don't want to use my toilet you know
what I mean like I guess you're a big
star and everything and but but what did
you learn I mean when you're an actor
and you're gonna play Gary Hart who's
still alive when you go there for three
days from a performance standpoint what
do you pick up like little texts or
little speech things on the performance
side it is what's it like to be in his
presence how does he make people feel
and I certainly picked up on his
incredible warmth and generosity well
yeah he let you use your bedroom you
know he that's that's generous just
beyond that like I am playing his life
this is his story it's his legacy it's
the it's bringing up thirty years later
a horrible moment in his life and what I
felt from
gary was care for me as an i I get that
this might be Harvey I'm gonna make you
feel at ease